aujourd'hui nous sommes devant une forme
de fracturation de la société française
qui devient une addition de communautés
qui ne se parlent plus ou qui ne se
reconnaissent plus de lien commun et ça
c'est notre affaire à tous sens
aujourd'hui nous avons devant nous un
défi immense qui est celui de refaire le
lien est de lutter avec énergie contre
les communautarismes qui se font jour
non pas seulement dans les services
publics ou à l'école mais dans la
société elle même mais contre lesquels
il faut il faut lutter il faudrait
proposer un menu macron devenir
peut-être un peu plus souvent sur le
terrain de venir rencontrer les locaux
la réalité des terres le cas quand on
discute avec des élus locaux quand on
discute avec des enseignants quand on
discute avec des acteurs sociaux on ne
peut que constater qu'aujourd'hui oui
nous avons un vrai problème à faire
vivre la laïcité sur le terrain dans la
société la laïcité ça n'est pas
seulement une sorte de règle abstraite
qui s'imposerait uniquement dans les
services publics c'est aussi je le
disais la protection de ceux qui croient
et de ceux qui me croient pas la
protection des convictions mais c'est
aussi le fait que effectivement et c'est
par exemple le cas dans le débat
démocratique nous devons venir à cette
expérience démocratique avec des raisons
et non pas avec d'abord des
revendications communautaristes